- Gary V.
- What's up my man?
- Thanks for having me.
- Thanks for coming in.
- I wanted to come because
I know you have
another book coming out.
- I do.
- #AskGaryVee.
- Yes sir.
- I'm a big fan.
- Thank you.
- I get a lot of wisdom
and insight from you.
Motivation as well.
A lot of things that you say
and you talk about,
I already believe
and I already feel.
I feel like we're torn from the
same cloth, but I'll listen to
you and I'm like,
"That's right."
- Reaffirm it.
- It reaffirms it. Exactly.
- Uh-huh.
- It educes what you
what you already know.
I'm going to give example.
You give a lot of
boxing analogies.
- I do.
- I'm an ex-boxer.
That's my love.
- Me too.
- There's a coach who was
criticized for taking this guy,
this boxer who's already an
elite level boxer and another
coach criticized him says,
"You didn't do nothing for him.
"He's already there.
"You're just cheerleading."
This coach said,
"OK. Maybe he needed a
cheerleader at that moment."
You know what I'm saying?
- Yes.
- That's real. That's real.
- That is super real.
- Anyway, I
wanted to come to--
- I like that.
- I want to share we have
somewhat a different audiences.
- Yeah.
- But it does
crossover and it's a lot.
I wanted give you my audience.
- I appreciate that my man.
- You know what I mean?
And I try to give them as
much good stuff as
possible and I just want
them to know about you.
- I appreciate that my man.
- You know what I mean?
No doubt. No doubt.
- We're all the same.
That's what DRock's
said for right now.
- DRock.
- I appreciate it man.
Yeah, listen.
I keep my stuff very basic.
I think we all deploy
thesis against our executions.
You were just talking before we
went on film of the audience of
people that are working
out or in great shape.
You're like, "Great. That's
one part of the equation."
You take the mentality in the
thesis and you deploy
it against that genre.
I do the same thing.
I think, that's when
we probably crossover.
There's a lot of people trying
to start businesses,
trying to start their companies,
get theirs, and for me,
I just want to get them
to think about things
that are higher plane.
- Right.
- I always say it's
tactics versus religion.
- Mm-hmm (affirmative).
- Right? Please.
- Can you explain
that in layman's?
Break that down so
they understand?
- Sure.
I'll explain it a
couple different ways.
One I'll give some
tangible for the audience.
Right now everybody's
talking about Snapchat, right?
I'm a big believer that
Snapchat's the next platform.
It's a YouTube.
It's a Facebook.
It's a big deal.
Somebody called me out on my
last #AskGaryVee Show and said,
"You're not giving
us the right answer."
I really went at him,
because I'm like,
"'Cause you're looking for a tactic."
- Right.
- You're looking for me
to say, "Do ten push ups."
- And you're going to have...
Right.
- Post this on Thursday at four
o'clock with seven letters in it
and this picture and the problem
is tactics change too much.
The market changes too much.
I've started finally taking
care of my health in
the last two years.
The things I did 18 months ago
for my body aren't the right
things for me right now.
- Right.
- No different than your
"He might've needed a
"cheerleader right now."
- Right.
- The reason I always
talk about tactics.
Jab, jab, jab, right
hook, back to boxing.
That's a fucking textbook.
- Right.
- It's pure tactics.
- The truth is, and you know
this, is it's getting people to
understand the religion.
Understanding why
you're doing stuff.
- Right.
- For me, I'm always reverse
engineering, like,
"What do I want to happen?"
Then how do I get
there backwards?
How do I provide value?
I'll give you an example.
You know what's so interesting?
This is actually a
great way to say this.
This is a phenomenal situation
right now because you started
with, "I just want my
audience to know you and
"bring them good stuff."
How did this happen today?
That was a good thing by you,
that you wanted to
put me on to your world.
My reverse is, I'm
spending the last month,
my publisher and PR people are
yelling at me because they're
like, "You're passing on Wall
Street Journal and you don't
"have enough time to do the
Journal and CNN and CBS, but
"you're doing this
cockamamie podcasts."
- Right. Right.
- It's like, so to me, I can do
the math, I know how many people
you have on your
channel and this and that.
I don't need to always
do the biggest thing.
You go where you feel is right.
- Right, right.
- I could be on the Today Show
right now and I may have reached
seven million people, but
maybe 700 of them feel me.
- Right.
- Whereas I can do something
like this or the other things
that I've been doing that they
got all upset about and it may
only reach 100,000 or 500,000
but 4,000 may feel me or it's
just 700 or it may be 100
but it feels right to me too.
- Right, right.
- That's, people are not
navigating their lives with
enough intuition and long term.
To me, the energy of you
reaching out felt like
the right thing to do.
I don't know to even explain
it and it's now, here we are.
Today, starting right after this,
we do some daps,
a little love on the way out,
we go back but
we've started our relationship.
- Right, absolutely.
- I don't think people think
about the finish line enough.
They're thinking about what's in
it for me right now and they're
not thinking about seven,
twelve, nineteen,
forty four years from now.
- Right, let me speak on--
- Please.
- the origins of how I got here.
- Okay, so I got a DM from, I
believe, Brittany about the book
coming out etc, etc.
- On Instagram right?
- On Instagram.
- Just to let everybody know,
I'm doing a heavy Instagram
thing where we used a platform
called Ground Signal, you can
check it out, where we found out
people following me that data
showed had good audiences,
and I didn't reach out blind.
I reached out to people that are
already in my ecosystem and I
wanted to give them a free book
because they had audience and we
wanted to start a relationship.
Go ahead.
- Even if it was, even if you
were doing it blind,
I got the message.
- Yes.
- My closest friends are in this
room right now, yo check
this out, check this out.
They hit me up, right?
My guy here is like,
oh yeah I got that too.
I went really?
Let me see.
Same, I'm like, that's fine.
I'm going to respond, explain
who I am because how I am,
I'm like me and him need
to know each other.
We need to meet each other.
They're going to,
we'll end up linking up.
- Once they understand.
- Exactly and you're, I know
that you're a dynamic thinker,
you're a smart dude, I get it.
I know. It's like, I feel
like I really know you.
- You taste it.
- Yeah, exactly.
- You know why.
It's the same way I
felt in two seconds.
It's why we picked and chose our
spots, you can just taste your own.
I believe in that shit so much.
- I'm with you.
My mentality is like, I have
a, I don't lose mentality.
That's with anything,
that's not just like
say a sporting event or
whatever, that's just life.
Because life is nonstop test and
we are always being put to test.
There is always
challenges, obstacles et cetera.
I literally don't accept any
of that as an impediment,
as a negative.
It's like, "Good, this is going
to make me stronger, I'm going
to learn something from this."
- Do you like to lose?
- Fuck no, I don't even ...
- I do, and I'm probably saying
the same thing you just did.
I seriously get off on losing,
I love it, I fucking love it.
When play basketball, we play
basketball two times a week,
a bunch of people here at
VaynerMedia, 6 am tip.
You got to really want to
play and I'm up till midnight
hustling, I got to up like five.
It's crazy, I love when we go
4-and-0 because we shoot for teams
and I got the right team and
we are just more talented
and we're rolling.
But I'd be lying if I told the
world that I don't get an extra
special like buzz when
we lose the first three.
I love the climb.
- I'm going to tell you why?
- Please.
- Because this is something that
a lot of us have, some people
don't have is, when you are at
the bottom you have nowhere to
go but up. If you are not
literally at the bottom.
- It's all upside.
- Exactly, if you are not
literally at the bottom,
figuratively you got to be there,
you got to have your eyes
on the bigger guys, the bigger,
because that's what I do.
I'm always
comparing myself to--
- Something above you, a 100%.
- Yeah, people who are
doing way better than me.
- You want to hear
something crazy?
- Mhmmm.
- You see it right up
there, the wine business?
- Right.
- When I won, when there was
nobody in the wine business that
debated anymore that I built
the best wine shop, I was done.
- Right.
- It was over.
- Exactly. Exactly.
- As a matter of fact, I'm
worried about that with
VaynerMedia right now.
We've exploded.
We're up to 625 people.
We're becoming the shop.
- Right.
- It'll take a couple more years
because Madison Avenue's old--
- Right.
- and fucked up.
As soon as it happens I'm
scared because I'm like,
"Shit. It's going to happen again,"
and I'm going to want to go sell
potatoes or something.
- Right.
- Be the potato king.
- When you say you can taste
your own, perfect example.
One of my closest friends,
we always talk about
different scenarios.
"If you just got this
$500 million right now,
would you do this?"
- Yeah.
- He's like, "Yeah man, I'd just
kick back and just hang out
with my daughter."
- Chill.
- He said, "You wouldn't?"
I'm like, "I can't."
- There's no other gear.
- It's infinite possibilities.
You know what I mean?
Infinite.
- You know what I think
that's predicated on?
I'm curious if this
is what it's for you.
I'm just driven by legacy.
So much more,
I always say legacy's
greater than currency.
- Mhmmm.
- That's why I'm out
there and that's why
DRock's filming and that's
why I'm doing this stuff.
No question.
I'm excited right now that
my great-great-grandchild
is literally watching
this right now.
- Right.
- I'm long gone.
- For sure.
- They're literally
watching this right now.
- It's out there.
It's the same here.
When I go to my
children's school,
I'm winning.
They're winning.
You know what I mean?
- 100%.
- My son has a
YouTube channel now.
- Is that right?
How old is he?
- He's 10.
- I love it.
- He just turned 10.
They're seeing
the spelling bees.
They're seeing him working out.
They're seeing all of his stuff.
He gets it.
He's proud of his dad.
I'm proud of him.
Also with legacy
I love that you said that
because I was just talking to
some people about this.
When I first started in
the fitness industry,
we had photographers.
We had videographers.
Every expo on that.
People made fun of me
like, "What are you, famous?"
- Yeah, "What are you, famous?"
- "Paparazzi?"
Those same people are year, two
years later, "Hey, so about that
"YouTube thing."
- Yeah, "Can you put me on?"
- "Do you? What do you?
Can we?"
- "How do you do that?"
Of course.
- That's one thing, but
you're right, the legacy.
I look at it,
I'm not looking at it like, "Oh
I'm doing something better than
you that you're not doing."
No. I'm looking at it like legacy.
You know what I mean?
Ancient Egypt.
Ancient Greece. Rome.
They have these
fucking statues of--
- 100%
- Hieroglyphs.
This is our
modern method of that.
- There's another thing
that is quite interesting.
We, everybody who's watching
right now and listening,
we are the patriarchs and
matriarchs of our family.
We will be the first
generation that is heavily,
and I mean heavily, documented.
So, forever. Forever.
You're the
beginning of your family.
Sure thing, and I don't know how
many pictures of your parents or
videos of your parents, but for
97.9% of us outside of people
that had parents that were
famous, we are the starting
point, and I think
that's a huge responsibility.
I literally look at everybody
in this office and I'm like,
"My God, they are the person that
their family's going to be like,
'That was the chick that started it.'"
- Right.
- And that's a big deal--
and that's a responsibility
greater than anybody's ever had
to deal with in the past,
and I take that
responsibility in a big way.
I want to set up the
Vaynerchuk name-
- Yeah, for sure.
- in a legit way.
- For sure.
No doubt, no doubt,
so #AskGaryVee.
- Yes.
- Why, and what?
- I'll give you the real answer
and then I'll give you the
bullshit answer.
- All right.
- The real, real, real answer
is I love public speaking.
I don't get any high greater
than when I hit the stage.
That's my competition.
That's me walking into the ring.
I literally treat it that way.
I've recently told the truth of
how I think about the way I go
on stage which is, I want to
fight my audience,
I come with anger--
- Right, right.
- and honestly, I realized that
when I was doing Q &amp; A in the
last 15 minutes, that
was the biggest fire.
My talk was great and I'm
entertaining and good, but where
I really separated myself from
everybody was when I did Q &amp; A,
because I can really show my
skills; so 18 months ago when
DRock and I started the show, I
went on a very conscious effort
to brand myself
as the Q &amp; A guy.
- Right, right.
- So that my talks, going forward,
once I got bigger,
I could just roll on
stage and go, "Go."
Like that's what I
actually want to do.
- Right, right.
- That's why.
Why is there a book?
It's a triple reinforcement of
where I want to take the brand.
- Right.
- The more politically correct,
and true, but secondarily true
answer: it was the best book
that I could write right now and
I had one more book to
write on my contract.
- There you go.
- I got to deliver
and it was the best book
that I could write right now.
I've been stunned by
the early reaction.
My haters and my biggest fans
are agreeing on the quality of
it and that's why I think
I've got something with this.
- Right.
- Because it's a 360 view.
It's about parenting and empathy
and self-awareness and
work ethic and leadership, not just
how to use YouTube,
not just how to make
money using Facebook.
- Right and that's one of the
reasons why I'm a huge fan of
yours is because you
have VaynerMedia, right?
The underlying spirit of your
success is not just being a
social media guru or
whatever those title's are.
It is the fatherhood.
It is the fact that your like,
"Fuck this, I'm going
" to get in shape.
"I'm going to show you guys
what I'm going through."
All of the other things that
make you the man that you are
and that's one thing that I try
to convey to people that listen
to me and follow me.
In the fitness industry it's like
these people are just fitness.
- Did you see the video I made
about the fitness industry?
I was like, "Can you please show
me one picture when you just"
Listen, everybody knows you're
setting these pictures up.
It's your pump day and it's
perfect fucking lighting.
- This is the thing,
Gary, they don't know that.
That's the dangerous part of it.
These people are so
impressionable
they don't know it.
- That's a valid point.
You know what's funny?
What just happened.
We just both broke
down the same statement.
You're right and I'm
right in a ten year window.
What I'm trying to tell the
people that are taking the
perfect shots is, "You're
going to lose when it's not
authenticity
because eventually
and you can get yours."
There's big difference between
being rich and being wealthy.
There's a big difference between
having a couple of all-star
seasons and being hall of fame.
- Right, right.
- You're right, I'm not
breaking it down well enough.
People can get away with, and I
see the marketing all the time,
you can get away with a couple
of years where you make some
bank and you may think you're
clever and tricking the market,
you're just going
to lose over time.
- Absolutely. And see I look at it like this.
Those people and I'm
the guy who put
the reality in everyone's faces.
A lot of industry people
don't like me
but the people like me--
- Of course.
- And that's what I care about.
- And what do the
industry people not like?
I know what you're doing.
You're exposing truth.
What would you say is,
what are the top two things
you think, I'm just interested,
I'm just curious,
that you've exposed that the
industry reacted poorly to
and the people like yeah.
Well, first of all, until recent
times you have your gate keepers
Your big supplement companies.
- That's right.
- The promoters for shows, et cetera.
- Yeah.
- And people needed
that to make money.
- To appease them.
- Right.
Right. So I came through
in a different direction.
First of all, when I got into the
fitness industry I wasn't trying to.
I was just doing me on YouTube.
Right?
- Right.
And people loved it.
It grew to where it's at.
I now have a supplement
company, an apparel line,
I have a meal prep company.
- You did from the ground up.
- From the ground up.
When people asked me,
"So what you do?"
I'm like "It's a lot."
You know what I mean?
It's all from the ground up and
it's all without these "gatekeepers."
Now I'm letting people know
you don't need them anymore.
- Sure.
- They need you.
- 100%.
They need you and your audience
to help sell their product.
- Because YouTube and
Facebook and Instagram won.
- Exactly.
- Not this company.
- Exactly. And these
companies are seeing it.
So they don't like that.
- You showed by example.
- And I don't need them.
- So you have all the leverage.
- I'm letting people know
you don't need that shit.
- Were you an
entrepreneur as a kid?
Did you sell Blow-Pops
and flip shit?
- I was more of a
creative person.
- Interesting.
I played piano, saxophone,
tap danced.
A lot of people don't
know that but yeah.
- Tap dance shit is (inaudible).
- I wish I was a monster and
could say I tap danced.
I would milk the shit out of that.
- I was into science and stuff but--
- You are super nerdy?
- Yeah. I was.
- Were you always big though?
- No but I was always in shape.
- Got it.
- I always worked out. As a
boxer you can't gain weight.
It's impossble.
Every time I would stop
a gain like 20 pounds.
- When did you start boxing?
- 12.
- Where did you grow up?
- Brooklyn.
- Oh here. All here.
- Yeah.
But then I moved as a teenager
to Arizona to be with my father.
And at a young age I traveled
all over the place fighting.
- How old are you?
- I'm 36 now.
- So who'd you come up with?
- My father.
- I'm sorry. In the boxing game,
who'd you see as a young kid?
- Oh, I was right under
Floyd Mayweather actually.
That's cool.
I should have been
right there too.
I could've been right there
too and when I stopped
I couldn't watch
boxing for like five years.
- Why'd you stop?
- Just life.
Other opportunities
I thought were better.
Boxing is hard.
And when you start as a kid you
kinda get burnt out,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- But it's worth it.
- The mental undertaking--
- It's a tough game.
- I had gotten lazy because I
didn't have my father over me
all the time, however.
- And you were at that age
when other shit was going on.
- Exactly, girls and you know.
- Of course, life.
- Right, so I went to school
but those principles that he
instilled in me
then, they're here now.
Every group of friends I had,
I was always the guy getting
everybody to work out,
you know what I mean?
When I was 12 I was getting up,
jogging at 6 in the morning,
you know, and I just
did different things.
It made me, there's no boxing
team in high school
so I was an outsider,
you know what I mean?
- I'm the same, man.
It's funny.
I've been really, it's funny
like I almost put it on a shelf,
I talk a lot about him, you guys
that know my stuff know I talk
about working in my
dad's store when I was 14.
What I don't talk about is,
because of that, I didn't play
sports in high school, like I
played tennis for one year.
I couldn't.
When I say that I worked every,
I worked every weekend.
- Right.
- There was not a single
Saturday from the time
I was in eighth grade
on that I was available,
outside of the baseball card
shows, which was work too.
I get it. I was so outsider,
I on Friday would go
work at the store,
which meant that I didn't go to
the Friday high school parties.
- Right, right.
- The other thing and I'm sure
you felt this too, the craziest
thing about that and I've been
thinking a lot, by the way,
the reason I jumped on this is,
I've been thinking a lot about
what I want to do with the sixth
graders because what you
probably felt and what I
definitely felt and I'm
projecting, you tell me if
I'm right or wrong, when you're
playing a different game
than everybody else,
peer pressure doesn't even
have a shot on you.
- Oh yeah.
- Because you're already out.
Like, I was already out,
like I was looking at it.
I wasn't in it because I was
over here while everybody was
over here and man,
if you're lucky enough
to not feel peer pressure
in high school,
you can stay out of a
lot of fucking trouble.
- Oh yeah.
I never got in
trouble in school.
I was valedictorian,
you know what I mean?
I was the one black kid
in the chess club,
you know what I mean?
I'm not saying I was this
perfect angel but peer pressure,
it didn't even exist.
- It just didn't come in.
- And you talk about
self-awareness in the new book,
I bought the pre, I pre-ordered
and I read the sample
and I'm all about that.
I've been self-aware, I've had a
good level of consciousness as a
youth, when I was young.
- It's such a gift.
- I was aware.
- You knew what you
were good and bad at.
- Yeah, and I knew what to
stay away from by watching
other people,
you know what I mean?
- One hundred percent.
- When I seen people, I didn't
have my first taste of alcohol
until I was in my 20's.
- Me too.
- When I seen people drunk,
I'm like why do you all
want to be like that?
That's not cool.
You know what I mean?
- My end game with
socialization is like
getting a girl.
Not looking like an idiot.
You know what I mean?
- Yup.
- Yeah.
In terms that I hold self
awareness and consciousness.
Now, going back to fitness.
Right?
- Please.
- People misleading people
to look like they're
perfect all the time.
I feel like this is
like one little analogy.
I look at people like
we're animals essentially.
Right?
- Hundred percent.
- However, what separates us
from the animal kingdom is
self awareness,
consciousness, et cetera.
Like a dog doesn't
really have self awareness.
He'll take a shit
in front of you.
It's not embarrassing.
Hump a pillow.
It's whatever.
They don't have embarrassment.
We do, or we should. Right?
- We have a lot of
emotional intelligence.
- I'm looking at certain thing,
I'm like, "You're okay with
"lying or misleading like that?"
You know what I mean?
- You know what scares me the
most in this fitness world?
In the supplement world?
- Right.
- How many of my contemporaries,
because I can't call them
friends because of this one
action, are literally willing
for a buck to peddle product on
people that is not approved by
the FDA, that comes from China.
They have no idea what's in it.
I asked some of my homeys,
I'm like, "Dude, what if in
twenty-four months
multiple people die from
this shit that you're peddling.
You've no idea what's in it.
You're not taking it yourself,
but you want to make bank.
- Right.
- Sell T-shirts.
If you just want money,
sell anything besides shit that
people are putting in their
body, and can get fucked up,
because you have no idea
what's going to happen."
- Right.
No self awareness.
No embarrassment.
No emotional intelligence.
- No projecting.
- Right.
I started my supplement
company by accident.
I never took
supplements all my life.
Then, you know,
I was personal training,
and I was a successful trainer.
I had clients all day long
from 5:00 in the morning.
I close the gym.
I'm tired, I don't have energy.
- Sure.
- That's customer service.
I'm big on customer service.
You're paying me sixty to
hundred dollars for
an hour of my time.
- So you need to
step up your game.
- I need to be, you know.
I tired pre-workouts.
I like the energy, but it there
were certain side-effects that I
was getting, I didn't like.
I started researching. Right?
I don't have a background in--
- Sure. Chemical engineering.
- Chemical, right.
- Yeah.
Everything's on Google.
I'm researching.
After work, every night
I'm researching
all these ingredients.
I found out why I was
feeling the way I was.
I went to eBay and stuff like
that and found labs where I can
order raw materials.
- Yep. Hacking.
- I'm testing out stuff
on myself. Right?
Almost died with
my first prototype.
- Seriously?
- Yeah.
Because I didn't measure the
caffeine with a milligram scale.
I couldn't find it. You can't
find milligram scales.
They're hard to find.
You can get a gram--
- You get your heart
going so much?
- Yeah. I was in a mini
comma for a day.
I slept for
thirty-something hours.
Twenty-something hours.
You know what I mean?
Luckily--
- You didn't die.
- I didn't die.
- Thank God.
- I found out that I put the
equivalent of forty fat burners,
that much caffeine in
the tea that I drink.
Anyway, I learned, I did it.
I experimented on myself.
Finally got a good formula.
I feel like with any industry,
with the emergence of
social media when they see
people, following, growing,
growing, growing. You get
bombarded with pitches.
- Sure.
- One of my business partners
now who I was in the supplement
business with was like,
"Hey, you have ever think
about doing supplements?"
I said, "Funny you asked."
I took a picture of my
kitchen and sent it to him.
My kitchen was like a
laboratory, all these raw
ingredients, a lot of shit that
didn't work, shit that did work.
He was like,
"Damn, what's this?"
I explained,
I sent him my formula.
He was like,
"This is pretty different.
"This is interesting."
We came together and did it.
I was making it
just for me to take.
You know what I mean?
Then it blew into a whole ...
- This is my point
earlier in the story.
If you are not willing to
take it yourself, anybody who is
watching right now, you want to
make a buck, go fucking garage
sale and flip shit on eBay,
you can make a buck like
selling people stuff that
you are not taking yourself
is a scary proposition.
- Yes, they got to,
they die every day because they
look in the mirror every night
knowing that they
are full of shit.
- 100%.
- When I see people rising fast
and I know, I'm with you,
I got friends too, I won't
even call my friends.
- Acquaintances.
- People who come around--
- You got call them
acquaintances 'cause you are
scared to call them your friend
because you don't believe in the
shit they are doing.
- Exactly, and then they
are like, "You know what?
I'm going to do
supplements too."
I'm just like,
"All right guys, whatever."
It makes me want to get out of
the supplement business but we
formed, I just formed a new
company with two of my buddies
and we're getting out at
sports nutrition, period.
We are doing more
optimal health stuff.
Stuff you'll find
in a doctor's office,
you know that I'm saying?
Because I'm all about health
not just fitness industries.
I'm about being healthy.
- It comes down to intent.
- Right. Exactly.
- If you want to break it
down to its most basic form,
everybody wants to get
theirs, I'm not Mother Teresa.
I want to buy the
New York Jets, I need billions.
- There is nothing
wrong with that though.
- Especially when you don't
want to do it
at anybody else's expense.
- Exactly.
- I want to get there by doing
good, I want to get there by
giving you 51%
of this relationship.
It's 'cause I'm so good
that I know what
to do with my forty nine.
It comes down to talent.
The reason people want to
take eighty, ninety, 100% of the
relationship is they're
not good enough,
unless they take
100% of people's shit.
I'm good enough to like get
mine on 49% of the relationship.
Why do you think?
Of course people like me,
I'm giving them more
than I'm asking for in return.
- This is why I love you, dude.
Like I said, I'll hear something
you say that reaffirms
something that I'm doing.
You just did it.
This is my brother
right here, man.
When we were putting a deal
together for the documentary
we're doing and we came up with
the percentages and he said
what he was cool with, I said,
"Here's an extra five."
I love him.
He's fucking super talented.
And I'm not worried about
the money like that.
I'm doing all right.
We're doing projects,
everything that I'm doing, Gary,
it's 'cause I really fucking
want to do it and I
feel so good about that.
- You're going to feel the best
about it with the one thing that
you'll never get to
see happen,
which is literally
how I live my life.
I'm sure if you follow
me you've heard this,
everything I do is
predicated on my funeral.
I'll never get to see it,
which fucking sucks,
but I just basically want to--
- What if you do see it?
Who knows?
- If I do see it, then I'm coming
back on some different shit.
I'd be like,
"I'm the greatest."
At the end of the day,
if you really want to win,
I think living your life predicated
on everybody showing
up to your funeral,
and you know what?
It becomes your life.
I'm sure you guys
have met people,
it would never dawn on me
to do this and not say hello
and get everybody's names.
I watch it and I see
it in other places.
Why?
Who do you think you are?
More importantly,
when you have that big
of a north star,
it's not a tactic.
I consciously understand that
people take note that I do that.
- Right.
- I'm not confused.
I'm willing to admit that.
They also know if somebody's
doing it or not doing it.
- Right.
- It gets better.
This is where I believe
the truth is undefeated.
It's also better,
I'm really good with
faces, I'm shit with names.
My favorite part is, when I see
him at the Phoenix Airport,
I'm like, "Yo."
That's when people are like,
"Oh shit, he really did pay attention."
You know what I mean?
That's how I think life works.
I think the truth is undefeated.
I do think, over time,
everything gets exposed.
I see it every day,
people always ask
me about MLM companies.
I say, "I don't like them."
They get mad at me because
I'm acquaintances with
many people in that space.
I'm like, "Look,
I don't like it.
"I think all it is is
people selling people.
"It's not for me."
Now, who am I?
I'm not God.
I'm not judging anybody.
- Right.
- I have no interest in
everybody selling pills
that are killing people,
everybody that's doing ML
I'm not judging you.
You do you.
I have no interest in making you
feel good by me saying I believe
in what you're
doing because I don't.
- Right, right. Exactly
See, that's what I love.
Nowadays, I feel like society
has become so sensitive to where
I often feel like the bad guy
by speaking my mind
and being direct to people.
- You're the short-term bad
guy and the long-term good guy.
- Right. It comes back.
- Every time.
I live for, "I told you so."
This is where I'm vain.
This is where I'm not noble.
One of the biggest reasons I
think I'm a good guy
is 'cause I get
off on, "Told you."
- Right.
- I love it.
- I ... I mean I live for it.
- Mhmmm. Right.
I did a video talking
about people are like,
"You need to be more humble."
I'm like, "No I don't."
I said look up humble,
the definition of humble.
It's literally putting yourself
in a low rank in whatever
situation you are and I'm like,
"Look, I'm not saying I'm an
asshole, but--
- Let's take a step back
- But I'm confident as fuck.
- Let's take a step back here.
We're on your show right now.
You've been
plenty fucking humble.
You're being very kind to me.
You're putting me...
I think I'm as egotistical
as it gets and
I think I've got nothing
but humility too.
Like, it depends on
when people see you.
Like I'm first interacting
with you right now for real.
I see massive humility.
So I think that ...
You know, there's
also things like ...
Look what just
happened with Cam, right?
Cam was like,
"I'll show a good ...
You know, show me a good loser
and I'll show you a loser."
- Right.
- I believe in that shit.
- Like, everybody
is on Cam's ass.
Nobody was on Belichick's ass
for walking off the field and
shaking nobody's hand
when he lost the Superbowl.
- Right. Right.
- Like ... You know.
There's different zones...
First of all, I'm my worst
ego bravado when I'm on stage.
That's the context.
I feel like I'm on fire, I
feel like I want to come at it.
That's me there.
I'm the best and the most
humble when I'm having a meeting
one-on-one with somebody in here
that works for me that fucked up
and I'm propping them up.
I think that when you're living
your life in the open like
almost all of us are now--
- Right.
- You know, A, when you're
creating this much content like
both of us are, first,
I have empathy for
people think that
we're fabricating.
I don't think people know
how much, how nothing,
how nothing I touch
DRock's editing.
Zero.
- Right.
- But I don't think
anybody should believe me.
Because I wouldn't believe it.
- Right.
- Like, what do you mean?
You're putting, right?
- Yeah.
- So I get it.
I'm not mad at anybody.
It just comes down to the
truth will be right at the end.
- Right. Absolutely.
Same thing man.
I hate that I keep saying this.
He upload a video,
private and I just,
go ahead and put it up.
We don't do the go
back and forth at all.
- There's nothing to hide.
- The beauty with you and D-Rock
same with he and I, we're friends.
- Yeah.
- We're fucking,
we rock together.
- Honestly, I want to be less
of D-Rock's friend and
I'm not joking.
Because I don't like,
one of the things I fear,
so it was funny, D-Rock and I
are had actually a really
interesting moment the other day
where there's a lot that doesn't
make film because I'm firing
people, I'm having client cut.
Like there's stuff going on.
- Yeah.
- And there was just a rally of
like intense shit that day and
I get out of my meeting and
I look at D-Rock and I'm like,
"D-Rock, you ever think I'm
going to get my just due?"
And I was talking because I
could just see it in his eyes.
Like he's so close now.
Now he's really seeing
everything, everything.
- Right.
- And my true everything is way
better than what I can put out.
All my best shit is hidden
because it's the dark shit
where I'm the biggest light.
But I can't put it out because
it's somebody else's dark shit.
- It was funny.
We had a really nice
moment and I was like,
"Fuck. How do I ..."
DRock, over time, and this has
happened with him, he likes me
more because he knows me
even better than anybody else.
That's going to affect
the way he edits,--
- Right.
- because he can't help it.
He's a human being.
I'm trying to
figure out how to get
DRock to hate me a little bit.
To put out some shit that's but
it's interesting, isn't it?
It's super interesting that way.
- But it's good,
having somebody who knows
because this is life right now.
He knows your spirit.
He knows what to capture.
- Hey listen, at the
end of the day,
whatever you and I put
out on video and YouTube,
the bottom line is we're
interacting with too many,
there's 625 people
that work here.
There's probably been 2,000 that
have gone through the building.
They're all talking about me
and they're telling people over
dinner, "Ah, the truth is!"
Or "Ah, the truth is."
I know that and that's
how I try to live my life.
You know what I mean?
- Absolutely.
- I want people that I fire,
after they're okay with it
6 months later
to tell the truth.
I don't mind when the
first month out I hear stuff.
I'm like, "Of course,
they're bitter.
They're mad."
- Right.
- And they're struggling
and they're concerned.
There's only so much I can
do with severance and
stuff of that nature.
But, a year later, when
they're on the next chapter,
I want them to start reconciling
backwards and being like,
"That's a good dude."
- Mhmmm.
- If you do that,
you'll always win.
- I totally agree.
Gary, I don't want to
take too much of your time.
- I appreciate it.
- The book, "#GaryVee,"
March 8th?
- March 8th.
Look, it's the best book
ever written by a human being.
- There you go.
- That should be enough
to get people intrigued.
You know what I think honestly?
I think that this is exciting
to me because knew a little bit,
got a little more
sense just now.
If people like you,
they're watching this.
I think that the human
aspect of being a success
is not talked about enough.
People talk about the skills.
What's the hack?
What's the system?
How do you get 1,000
followers on Instagram?
How do you get 100,000
If I get 100,000, then people
are going to give me product.
Or Protein World is going to
want me to put them on, right?
- Right.
- I know the game.
I get it.
That shit is short term.
If people have latched onto
you and are watching this,
then I think what I wrote,
and look, you'll tell them
better and they'll trust you more,
but I tried to write a
blueprint for the entrepreneur
and the executive and
the human that looks
more like us than the masses.
- Right. Right.
The beauty of this is
one thing with social that I
want to get to the level of is
you attracted a fan who can
come to you and help put
your message out in the day.
- Of course.
- You know what I mean?
Because, essentially,
I'm a fucking fan.
- That's what happens when
you start providing value, and
that's going to
happen to you, man.
- My iBook there's like
four of your books
already in there.
You know what I mean?
- I appreciate it, man.
- It's not because I'm here.
It's been like that.
- You know what's funny?
It's happening to you right now.
If people are really
listening to you,
there's 7 to 10 of them
right now that are on their way
because authenticity
and quality,
the cream always
rises to the top.
It may be confusing at first.
Peyton Manning and Ryan Leaf
were supposed to be
as good as each other.
That shit will always, always,
always, always rise to the top.
People might not like the way
Floyd rolls with his bravado,
but if you're the
best, you're the best.
- You're the best.
One thing that I hold that
is comforting to my spirit is,
I have a big channel.
Google put me in the top
3% of fitness channels, right?
I don't like being in
the fitness box,
but I'll take it whatever.
- It's just a step.
- There's other people that
where I'll have 100 thousand
on this video in a week,
they'll have a half a
million in a week and
they're putting out bullshit, right?
I have comfort in the
people that are tuning
in to me are
solid fucking people.
- Dude, also ...
Go ahead.
- I'm not into the pop of it.
I want the critical acclaim.
- My man, I know I'm the
best businessman of all time.
I have 30,000 on YouTube.
I'm not crippled by that but
I built a $100 million a year
revenue business right here.
This company's going to
be worth a billion dollars
in a few minutes.
- Right.
- You can't let and
you, everybody watching,
don't get caught up in,
"Cool, I'm 250 on Instagram.
"I'm 1.2 on Twitter,
30,000 on YouTube because
"I stayed out of it, and whatever."
Letting social media numbers
dictate your success is asinine.
- When you get the,
listen, now I definitely know.
Now I can say this
without knowing.
When you get that email
every day, every day,
"Hey I saw your stuff and
it did this for me."
- Right, yeah.
I got an email from a woman
yesterday, a couple days ago,
I don't know if you
saw this DRock,
she said she was watching my
Super 8 when I was doing
my live stream thing.
She said she was in
Starbucks and this kid
literally was meeting with her,
talking about suicide
and watched it and it
flipped a switch in his head.
She's like,
"You're saving lives."
Now, I'm not going
to take that.
I'm not going to
hyperbolize that, first of all.
but second of all,
my man, you can have
500,000 people watching
but if you're not doing anything
of value to those people,
I'm super content with my 20 and 30
thousand because I know every
one of those people is getting
more value out of that than
99.9% of things, and
that's good for me.
- Man, I want to end on
this, for me at least.
I do a lot of expos and
I stand up there for hours
taking pictures, shaking hands,
and the common thing,
when I first started, all
they knew was the workout.
But now, the mental juice videos
don't do as big as the
workout videos, right,
and I won't stop doing
them because all that
people talk to me about is the
mental juice, the mental juice.
There's times I just flip
on the laptop and
just record from there.
I have something
heavy on my heart.
Something simple like,
"I know shit is hard.
"I know boom, boom
boom, boom but just do
"the right fucking thing."
- It'll never be
the wrong thing.
- Exactly.
- Ever.
- That's my thing.
When people come up to me and
talk to me about these things,--
- Yeah, man.
- I get fucking goosebumps.
You know what I mean?
- Me too, man.
Hey, did you start
playing with Anchor yet?
You see me promoting that?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You should do that.
You know why?
For guys like you and me, you
might be walking down right now
and have a thought,
yeah you got them but
boom, you just do it on
the phone and it's audio.
It's really good for guys
like us that have (snaps fingers)
Sometimes I'm just
taking a shit and I got it.
I don't know, it'd be weird.
I can do the Anchor. Yeah.
I had Snapchat when it
started but I never used it,
because I'm on everything.
- Yep.
- When I kept hearing you talk
about Snapchat, I was like,
"I need to give this a try."
There was already a ton of
people in there, waiting.
Sales across the board shot up.
It's not like I'm
really promoting on there.
- It just has the
attention, man.
The attention is real.
- Snapchat.
It was a pleasure, man.
- Real pleasure.
I really enjoyed it.
Thank you.
I'm real excited to get to
know you guys better as a crew.
- For sure, for sure.